should have their parents buy a new one.
You should have them do.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in the book of fasting
to finish up what we
were not able to finish during the last
during Ramadan.
We are at the close to the end of of the
book of fasting.
And
we were discussing the subchapter
regarding
those things which are
mendup. Those things which are highly
recommended, highly encouraged
that a person do during his time of
fasting while he is fasting or some of
these things may even be obligatory.
But the reason why the author put them
in this category and didn't put them in
the conditions, didn't put them in the
pillars is because one of these things
being compromised doesn't compromise the
validity of a person's fast. It may
compromise the reward of a person's fast
because
one of the things that he mentions in
this chapter is
is refraining from
and you know haram speech
haram speech haram action. Obviously the
this is this is obligatory. This is
binding. However, he put it in this
category because if a person were to
engage in that, it would not
invalidate
his fasting to the meaning that he
wouldn't have to make the day up.
Technically, he fasted technically.
However,
the reward of his fasting may be greatly
depleted, severely depleted, completely
depleted depending on the severity of
the action. And we remember the
narration of
there are some fasting that the only
thing they
gain by fasting is hunger. We know
this narration. We've shared it a number
of times. So
what would cause this to be the case?
Well, if a person does what is haram or
does what invalidates the spirit of
fasting even though they technically
physically fasted then yeah sure their
fast is technically
valid meaning in the sense that they are
not told to redo it. However,
the reward of that fast has been greatly
depleted or even entirely depleted to
the point where there's no reward at
all. And the same thing goes with fah.
The same thing goes with the same thing
goes with even right.
So a person can
do the right thing
do the act of kindness or do the act
of worship but then invalidate the
reward for it right in a specific sense
and in a general sense.
So
the last thing that we spoke about in
this chapter is
that when a person breaks his fast,
he breaks his fast on
fresh dates or dried dates
or water.
We mentioned that narration. The
narration is in sunb.
The final thing that the author mentions
in this chapter, that which is
encouraged,
that which is highly encouraged that a
person fasting does while he is fasting,
he says
that a person break his fast with the
recorded dua from that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was narrated to
have made. And then he cites the
narration of Abdullahbar
who says
[Silence]
Omar narrates
that the prophet sallall.aii
When he would break his fast, he would
say the dua. Three sentences. Three
sentences.
The thirst has been quenched.
And the veins have been quenched
inshallah. And the reward has been
affirmed. Be it the will of Allah.
Now there are other narrations
that mention
other
supplications
that a person make
when he breaks his fast.
All of those other narrations are
inauthentic. Some of them are not even
narrations,
right? Some of them are not even
narrations.
I'll give you an example. What does that
mean? Not even narrations. So
for instance, one of the
videos and narrations that were being
posted and sent around every year this
happens
is a quote unquote narration
where it says
Ramadan
Ramadan,
right? So, you know
what the prophet used to say
when he would bid farewell to Ramadan.
There's no narration this anywhere.
This narration actually comes from the
books of the Shia. This is one of their
narrations, right?
,
and
there are lots of narrations. This is
why social media is so dangerous because
even if a person finds a narration and
finds out that it is wrong or incorrect,
it's still
for the most part, right? The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam used to seek
refuge in Allah from knowledge that
doesn't benefit.
these are very dangerous things. This
is the same as a person taking a loaded
gun and running around pointing it at
people in the supermarket. Right? This
is this is dangerous.
This is very dangerous. and these
things are constantly sent out. I mean,
if I had a nickel for every fabricated
narration, every narration that has no
origin that someone has sent to me or
asked me about on social media, I would
be a very wealthy man today. So, it's
very important to steer clear of this.
And before social media,
it took the form of placards,
right? whether it be
posters or framed pictures or you
know placards where people would go to
Hajj, people would go to Omrah and they
would go down to the marketplace and buy
things to take home and they would have
these posters or pictures or
sometimes framed photos or something
that you hang on your and it would have
a dua on it or it would have a
narration on it. And the idea is well,
I'm sure that this is an authentic
narration because of course they
wouldn't go to the trouble
of making all of this and sometimes it's
someone makes it, you know, artistically
themsself, right? and think, "Wow, I
mean, of course, this is authentic." I
mean, how would it not be authentic? Of
course, if someone went to all this
trouble, then it's authentic. The amount
of fabricated narrations, the amount of
there, I've even found some of these
that have quote unquote narrations on
it. They're not even from the Quran or
the Sunnah or even the books of the
Shia. They're from the books of
and it's written
1 2 3 4 5. So just because it's on the
wall or just because it's written in
golden letters or just because it is
sculpted or looks artistic or looks like
someone went to a lot of trouble. This
is not the this is not the yard stick,
right? There's a lot of things which are
ascribed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam which are
not authentic. And so the duas for
breaking fast
the dua for
bidding farewell to Ramadan etc. All
of these they are not authentic or some
of them are not even in the books of
hadith at all.
So the next chapter that the author
gives us is
what is permissible for the person who
is fasting and he mentions a few things
which we discussed before. Number one
is that a person bathe to cool off
and we discussed this a few days ago.
Number two
is to rinse one's mouth and nose with
water without exaggerating to the point
where they would swallow the water. And
we took a lot of rulings with respect to
this. And
one of the things of our culture today
that falls into this ruling is also
using toothpaste. Is it permissible to
brush a person for a person to brush
one's teeth using toothpaste while he is
fasting? The answer is yes. There's no
problem with that. As long as they do
not as long as they follow the
guidelines of what the prophet
sallallahu
not exaggerate
in taking this
water or toothpaste or whatever it is to
the back of his throat or deep into his
nose to where it would go down his
throat or her throat. And
a lot of people they they find this
uncomfortable, you know, brushing
your teeth with toothpaste while you're
fasting. And that's fine. There's a
difference though between uncomfortable
and impermissible,
right? Something is impermissible means
it's haram. We cannot say something is
haram without evidence.
However, inappropriate,
uncomfortable.
,
this is something that is a much broader
a much broader topic. Can something
be is it is it particularly appropriate
for a person to brush his teeth with
with toothpaste while he is fasting?
it may be uncomfortable may be
inappropriate in the sense that there
are better times to do this.
However there is a big difference
between that and something that is
haram. We can't call it haram unless
Allah and his messenger have called it
haram. the next thing that we
mentioned is
which is drawing blood bloodletting
for the purpose of medicine. And what
follows this as well is
giving blood, donating blood, having
blood drawn, having blood drawn for
tests. None of this will break a
person's fast.
However, if a person
becomes severely depleted in doing so to
where they they need to, you know, they
become laded or of course then a person
should break his fast. Not only can a
person break his fast but in this kind
of instance it would become the sunnah
highly encouraged that a person break
his fast right which is one of the
reasons the scholars site that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentioned that the person who
gets hij bloodletting done that they
have broken their fast remember the
narration
right that both the one who does the
bloodletting and the one who has the
blood flooding done both of them break
their fast. So one of the reasons that
the person that has it done breaks his
fast is to replenish the body. You've
just taken the life,
you know, the the liquid life out of the
body, which is blood. It needs to be
replenished. It needs to be restored.
But does it that in itself break a
person's fast? No, it does not break a
person's fast in itself. We discussed
this in
in u
detail during Ramadan.
So tomorrow inshall we will move on to
the fourth point which is
meaning
this one is for that guy right and that
is
kissing one spouse or flirting with one
spouse or petting or all these other
things that people do that occurs
between a man and his wife. that
these things are permissible
while a person is fasting for those
who are able to control themselves. So
we'll talk about that one tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]
note somebody left for you. I want to
give it to you now. I keep forgetting
my